in the vast landscape of machine
learning where algorithms strive to
unlock the Mysteries hidden within vast
data sets a powerful technique emerges
and simple learning like a symphony of
Minds working in Harmony and Sample
learning combines the diverse
perspectives of multiple models to
create an entity greater than the sum of
its parts just as a conductor unifies
musicians to create a captivating melody
in summer learning orchestrates the
collective intelligence of individual
Learners producing predictions of
unparalleled accuracy and robustness
growing inspiration from the wisdom of
crowds this captivating approach
explores the art of collaboration among
algorithms leading us to a world with
the whole truly surpasses the individual
in the pursuit of knowledge according to
decent studies Ai and machine learning
related job postings have increased by
344 in past five years companies across
the globe are actively seeking
professionals who can harness the power
of data and build intelligent systems
the average salary is 150 000 in the US
and 15 lakhs per annum in India so if
you want to become an expert Ai and ml
professional with this pgp in Ai and ml
that is delivered in partnership with
IBM the artificial intelligence course
covers the latest tools and Technologies
from the AI ecosystem and features
master classes by Caltech faculty and
IBM experts hackathons and ask me
anything sessions this program showcases
Caltech ctm is excellence and IBM's
industry progress the artificial
intelligence course key Concepts like
statistics data science with python
machine learning deep learning NLP and
reinforcement learning through an
Interactive Learning model with live
sessions and all now and unlock exciting
Ai and ml opportunities the course link
is mentioned in the description box
below with that having said hey everyone
welcome to simple learns YouTube channel
but before we dive into that don't
forget to like subscribe and share and
in this video record topics like what is
in simple learning and after that we
look what is bagging and boosting
following that we will cover steps to
perform bagging and boosting after this
we look at some advantages of packing
and boosting and at last we'll see the
difference between bagging and boosting
so without any further Ado let's get
started
and we'll start with what is Ensemble
learning then sample methods in machine
learning combines the insights obtained
from multiple learning models to
facilitate accurate and improve
decisions
Ensemble learning enhances machine
learning outcomes by combining multiple
models leading to Superior predictive
performance in contrast to using a
single model
the fundamental concept involves
training a group of classifiers referred
to as experts enabling them to
collectively make predictions through
voting begging and boosting represent
two types of Ensemble learning
techniques both methods effectively
reduce the variability inherent in a
single estimate by combining multiple
estimates from diverse models
consequently the outcome can be a more
stable model let's first take a look at
some real world examples that will
simplify the concepts that are at the
core of Ensemble learning example one if
you are planning to buy an air
conditioner would you enter a showroom
and buy the air conditioner that the
salesperson show you the answer is
probably no in this day and age you are
likely to ask your friends family and
colleagues for an opinion do research
and on various portals about different
models and visit a few review sites
before making a purchase decision in a
nutshell you would not come to a
conclusion directly instead you would
try to make a informed decision after
considering diverse opinions and reviews
and moving forward let's see what is
begging and after that we'll cover what
is boosting machine learning
so we'll start with what is begging
bagging also known as bootstrap
aggregating it's an ensembled learning
technique that helps to improve the
performance and accuracy of machine
learning algorithms it is used to deal
with bias variants trade-offs and
reduces the variance of a prediction
model begging avoids overfitting of data
and is used for both regression and
classification models especially for
decision tree algorithms now we'll see
steps to perform bagging
so first consider there are n
observations NM features in the training
set you need to select a random sample
from the training data set without a
replacement and then you have a subset
of amp features that is chosen randomly
to create a model using sample
observations
the feature offering the best split out
of the load is used to split the nodes
the tree is grown so you have the best
root nodes
and the above steps are repeated end
times
it Aggregates the output of individual
decision trees to give the best
prediction so these are the steps to
perform bagging now we will move to
advantages of bagging in machine
learning
so the First Advantage is bagging
minimizes the overfitting of data the
next is it improves the model's accuracy
and the third Advantage is it deals with
higher dimensional data efficiently
and now we'll see what is boosting in
machine learning after seeing the
advantages of bagging now we'll move to
boosting
so boosting is an assemble modeling
method that aims to create a robust
classifier by combining multiple V
classifiers this technique involves
constructing a sequence of models using
weak models initially a model is built
using the training data subsequently a
second model is constructed which seeks
to rectify the errors made by the first
model this process is iterated with
additional models being added until
either the entire training data set is
accurately predicted for the maximum
number of models is reached now we'll
see steps to perform boosting
the training process for boosting models
varies depending on the specific
boosting algorithm employed however in
general an algorithm follows these steps
to train a boosting model now we'll see
those steps and the first step is the
boosting algorithm initially assigns
equal weight to each data sample it then
feeds the data into the first base
algorithm also known as the base model
the base model generates predictions for
each data sample and then we have the
Step 2 the boosting algorithm evaluates
the predictions made by the base model
and increases the weights of samples
with larger errors it also assigns
weight based on the performance of the
model
a model that produces more accurate
predictions will have a greater
influence on the final decision and then
we have the step 3 the algorithm passes
the weighted data to the next iteration
which typically involves training
another decision Tree on model then we
have the step 4 the algorithm repeats
Step 2 Step 3 iteratively until the
training errors Falls below a specific
threshold or until a predefined stopping
Criterion is met now we'll see the
advantages of boosting the First
Advantage is it effectively handles data
sets with higher dimensions
and other Advantage is it effectively
handles missing values and maintains
accuracy even with incomplete data now
this is the time to see the difference
between bagging and boosting so we'll
start with begging
so randomly selected subsets of training
data that are drawn with the
displacement from the entire training
data set and in boosting every new
subset includes the elements that were
incorrectly classified by preceding
models and the next differences
backing aims to address the problem of
overfitting and in boosting it aims to
minimize bias
and if we talk about the bagging when
the classifier exhibits instability with
high variance the application of bagging
becomes necessary
and in boosting when the classifier is
stable and straightforward indicating
High bias the application of boosting
becomes necessary and in begging each
model is assigned an equal weight
whereas in boosting the models are
assigned weights based on their
performance and in begging the object is
to reduce variance rather than bias and
while in boosting the objective is to
reduce bias rather than variance and
with that we have come to the end of
this session if you have any doubts
please feel free to comment down in the
comment section and our instructors
would be happy to help you till then
stay safe keep learning and get ahead
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here